the blue fire is considered the most
thrilling roller coaster at aroma Park
so I wanted to try it myself
we are just supposed to take off I'm a
bit scared but I'm sure we see us again
this ride goes from 0 to 100 km/h in
just two and a half seconds
highlight of course is the live to live
what an adrenaline rush
I survive I'm a bit shaken up but it was
really fun it was a perfect way to start
my day here at The Oval Papa so join me
and let's see what else we can discover
here the park is so big that I need a
map to navigate my way around there are
more than a hundred different
attractions here including 11
rollercoasters
one of the new attractions is the dome
of dreams a multimedia 360 degree cinema
right now they're showing a program
called beautiful Europe
there's a good reason for calling this
place or oppa Park Russia Greece Iceland
and many other European countries are
represented here each country has its
own special attractions in Spain for
example you can enjoy a show called the
return of the Black Knight
in fact there's so much to see and do
that you can't cover it all in a single
day so it decided to ask some park
staffers for a few inside tips the first
one is when you come in the morning
always go to the back of the park
because the visitors usually stay at the
front of the park trying the rides over
there and there you have longer lines
while in the back it's still very empty
so just go to the back and enjoy the
rides over there and do you have other
recommendations like inside our
recommendations go for lunch not between
12:00 and 2:00 because the Germans like
to have lunch always at the same time so
the lines in the restaurants a bit
longer while there were riots have
actually shorter lines and if you don't
feel like having a restaurant Mia you
can bring your own food picnickers are
welcome now let's take a boat ride on
the Europa Park Lake and use the
opportunity to ask other visitors what
they like best about the park
it's walking in the park it's seeing all
these beautiful decoys all the countries
that are representing I really like it
here the blue fire is sensational it's
really fast
I like the Silver Star best it's a real
rush it's just amazing it's the best
park
about five million people visit our oppa
park every year it's especially popular
with young people
my visit here is just about over I'm now
at the super slash Atlantica at the
Portugal seam area
this attraction is really popular in the
summertime because chances are you'll
get an impromptu shower which will help
you cool off as you can see I really got
wet but this is perfect with this
weather so I lay down on in the Sun to
dry so goodbye from the yoga papa